welcome ancient astronomers view
disguise differently than we do cast
your mind back to what it would be like
in ancient times you step outside at
night you can see over a thousand stars
you'll know many of the stars personally
because they illustrate stories you've
been hearing all your life you use those
stars to tell time to determine
directions and to know when to plant and
harvest the perfect regularity of the
cycles in the sky is the only guaranteed
aspect of your life your worldview is
partly defined by the skies and many
ancient astronomers are still telling us
that we live in a small world where the
heavens are ruled by gods and heroes
when you see transient or regular events
and skies like comets or meteors or even
planets it seems like these can only be
messages from the gods
the point is that ancient astronomy have
different tools and different goals than
does modern astronomy and yet despite
these differences we also have a rich
heritage coming to us from ancient
astronomy ancient astronomers made many
remarkable discoveries and achieved many
remarkable feats these were built on
many thousands of years of sky watching
the most famous stars in the sky are
what we call the Big Dipper but these
same stars form part of what is referred
to as a Great Bear image in the sky but
did you know that people have been
calling this a Great Bear for at least
fourteen thousand years and perhaps more
than thirty thousand years the same
stars are depicted of the Great Bear by
something like half of the culture
throughout both Eurasia a.m. North
America the fact that the Eurasian
installation is widely duplicated in
North America suggest that this idea was
carried across the Bering Strait with
the original settlers around 14,000
years ago
this makes the Great Bear one of the
oldest intellectual properties of
mankind did you know that the Great
Pyramid in Egypt has its edges aligned
north-south and east-west to an
astounding accuracy of 120th of a degree
that's an angle getting near the
resolution of the human eye it was only
10% of the size of the full moon for the
three big pyramids on the Giza Plateau
the average accuracy is about the same
while the scatter of the three
orientations is just about passed the
moon size this high accuracy is hard to
do even with care with modern technology
what is clear is that such alignment
must have been done with the help of the
skies by people we would call
astronomers astronomers of many cultures
have been working deeply on the
observations and theory of the positions
of the Sun Moon planets and stars it's
remarkable that the Mayans Chinese
Indians Babylonians and Greeks all had
measured the orbital periods of the
planets two parts per million accuracy
even two millennia ago and did you know
about the recent startling discovery in
2016 that the Babylonians around 200 BC
or so we're following the position of
the planet Jupiter in the sky using a
numerical method that is essentially
integral calculus this confident new
discovery is surprising to modern
scientists and historian because it's so
long before the first step towards
calculus in the 1300s by mathematicians
in Oxford did you know that the real
historical origin of the Star of
Bethlehem has now been identified with
good consonants perhaps the Stars our
most famous sky symbol as reported in
the Bible at the birth of Jesus over the
centuries an incredibly wide range of
ideas been proposed it's the nature of
the
are but a startling discovery seems to
have established conclusive evidence the
historical date for the star mentioned
in the Gospel of Matthew this was
published in 1999 by Michael Mullen our
historian of astronomy from Rutgers it's
not what anyone would have expected
molar solution is that the Star of
Bethlehem is a report of a natal
horoscope that points ancient
astrologers to the birth of a very great
king in Judea
on 17 April 6 BC the validity of his
solution have been sweeping through the
scholarly communities did you know about
the discovery of an awesome analogue
computer in a shipwreck off of the
island of Antikythera near the Greek
mainland dating to around 100 BC the
complex year mechanism was pulled up off
of the floor of the Mediterranean in
1901 the workings of the Antikythera
mechanism have only been revealed
starting in 2005 when the corroded
bronze years have been given a thorough
three-dimensional x-ray scan the gears
served to provide a full calendar
warning of eclipses times telling of the
dates of Olympic Games and other
festivals giving lunar phases and all
the planet positioned back here to
something like one degree this geared
computer is arguably the greatest
achievement in all astronomy the for the
year 1500 our course will cover a very
wide range in both time and space we'll
be talking about events and people from
around 4000 BC up to the Renaissance and
we'll cover all the inhabited continents
[Music]
perhaps most famous example from all of
ancient astronomy of Stonehenge the
astronomical key to this site is the
fact the main axis of the monument
points at midsummer sunrise so I'll
spend the red
of this lecture and the next lecture
telling you about the archeoastronomy
archaeology and latter-day history of
Stonehenge Stonehenge is a wonderful and
awesome Monument it's on the South very
plain in south central England just a
two-hour drive from London the basic
structure is a set of standing stones
set in a circle that surrounds a
horseshoe shaped set of standing stones
the central set of stones consists of
five pairs of very tall stones topped by
a horizontal stone called a lintel each
of these so called tri Lathon have the
lintel stone pegged to the vertical
stone with a mortise and tenon joint
newsies joints heavens knob sticking out
of the top of the standing stone that
fits into a hole in the lintel so the
lintel can't easily fall off the tallest
reaches 24 feet from the ground the
biggest stones are 40 tons
the horseshoe of tryla fons is
surrounded by a circle of stones the
basic circle originally consisted of 30
standing stones each talked by two
lentils to form a continuous ring
running around the top the stones in the
circle are made from a sand stone rock
called sarsen each of the stones has
been pounded into a roughly rectangular
shape
there's chasing a stone that is rare
amongst stones that other
contemporaneous stone circles around the
British Isles this is the basic monument
although many of the original stones
have fallen down or been taken away the
immediate vicinity of stonehenge has a
complex array of remains to go far past
the basic monument centered on the
monument is a circular ditch with a
radius of 180 feet the chalk dug out
from the ditch was heaped into a bank
running just inside the ditch the ditch
doesn't form a complete circle as there
are sections to the south and to the
northeast that form openings into the
central area the opening
towards the Northeast forms part of a
long linear feature called the Avenue
the Avenue is defined by two parallel
ditches running out from the circular
ditch around the monument this Avenue
goes perfectly straight for 2,000 feet
before veering to the right and
ultimately running down to the River
Avon at the start of the Avenue just
where it touches circular ditch is that
now fallen dressed Rock given the
colorful name of the slaughter stone
this name invokes an image of a ritual
sacrifice ism and people imagined the
victim laid out on the stone just a bit
outside the ditch just off-center in the
Avenue is the upper right heel stone the
heel stone is famous because it defines
the astronomical alignment of Stonehenge
that is on the morning of the June
solstice the longest day of the year if
you're at the center of Stonehenge
you'll see sunrise over the heel stone
there are many more stones and pits
within the central ditch area these form
a circular array of 56 pits called the
Aubrey holes each of these about 3 foot
in diameter and 3 foot deep nearly on
top of these abri holes are for
undressed stones that define a rectangle
these are called station stones two of
the station stones are surrounded by
small ditches close around the basic
stone circle are two more rings of holes
irregularly spaced and the center of the
whole circle has one stone
given the evocative name of the altar
stone this stone is now fallen and lying
mostly buried under a lintel fallen from
a tree Lafond Stonehenge and all its
surroundings were made by a culture of
Neolithic farmers given the name beaker
people they flourished throughout the
British Isles in the Western Europe from
the late Stone Age to the early Bronze
Age Stonehenge was built in stages from
we 3100 BC to 1600 BC the first
construction was the ditch and Bank plus
the Aubrey holes plus the station stones
and these were all built around 3100 BC
the basic circle and the inside try
Lathon were made from sarsen stones they
were put in place around 2500 BC this is
the basic Monument from then until 1600
BC less impressive circles were made of
the smaller blue stone rock with various
rearrangements over the centuries so
larger area surrounding Stonehenge is
filled up with contemporaneous monuments
these are dominated by burial mounds of
many types further there are a variety
of other circles or hinges throughout
the area one of them called Blue
Stonehenge was recently discovered where
the Avenue arrived at the River Avon
this was apparently made out of the same
blue stones that were that are now at
Stonehenge itself Stonehenge was built
with only primitive tools archeologists
find many broken antler tips inside the
pits and ditches these were the tools
used to dig in the ground
many modern reenactments have been made
where small crews of people have moved
stones long distances stressed the
stones and set them upright all this is
just all this with just ropes logs and a
lot of effort this is impressive
the largest stone weighs 40 tons to me
the most impressive point about the
construction is that the stones used
were transported tremendous distances to
be brought to Stonehenge the big sarsen
sandstone were dragged eighteen miles
from marl barrel down to the north the
smaller blue stones were dragged and
perhaps floated by raft from queries in
Wales about 150 miles away that's an
incredible amount of effort to get
particular stones from afar while local
stones are apparently not good enough
perhaps the bluestones were holy for
some reason although we'll never know in
any case the Stonehenge builders must
have had some incredibly strong
motivation to drag in stone from so far
away the basic astronomy of Stonehenge
is an alignment toward the sunrise at
midsummer that is if you stand in the
center of the Stonehenge circle look out
down the Avenue over the top of the heel
stone then you'll see sunrise at exactly
that position on June 21 let's see how
this works is the premier exemplar of
archeoastronomy the word archeoastronomy
can generically refer to the study of
astronomy as it was practiced in ancient
times but there's also much more
specific meaning having to do with how
ancient peoples built monuments aligned
to the Stars the basic paradigm of our
Co astronomy is that ancient peoples
incorporated astronomy into their old
temples and other structures by pointing
to a particular direction around the
horizon where something significant
happened such directional symbolism is
universal in all cultures including our
own the reasons are widely varied but
they're always there they always go back
to the astronomy and they're often
charged with strong cultural traditions
for most ancient peoples these
alignments are a common way to interact
with the sky but the astronomical
origins might have been partly lost on
the common folk the basic setup of our
key astronomy is that some now ancient
building is pointing at some direction
on the horizon the pointing might use
some obvious main axis of building plan
or or the architecture can somehow
indicate a position for an observer to
stand plus some stone marking a
direction to look this is like the stone
marking a foresight and a back sight for
aiming a gun the position
an observer to stand could be given by
the center of a circle throne statue or
the top of a grand staircase the
direction to look might be marked as
down some central axis along a wall
perpendicular to a wall or by some
distant stone the astronomically
significant direction on the horizon is
usually one of the four cardinal
directions or one of the four social
directions the four cardinal directions
are usually north east south and west
before are so special directions are
towards either sunrise or sunset on the
dates of either the summer solstice or
the winter solstice these selfs tichel
directions are the sun's extreme north
during summer and the sun's extreme
south during winter the days the
solstices are close to june 21 and
December 21 every year for people in the
southern hemisphere summer and winter
have to be reversed in addition there's
a lot of talk about the moons equivalent
extreme rise and set direction also in
rare cases the significant direction can
be towards the rise of some bright star
well know what the cardinal directions
are but social directions aren't so
commonly known so let me tell you more
about them well the prime cause is that
the Earth's rotation is tilted by close
to 23 degrees when compared to the plane
of its orbit around the Sun we've all
seen this represented by the tilt of the
North Pole and the standard desk globe
the globe has the equator in the pole
tilted by 23 degrees with respect to the
horizontal even over many years our
Earth's polar axis will not move so it's
always pointing in the same direction
called the North Pole so as our earth
moves around the Sun in its orbit the
northern hemisphere is tilted
alternately towards the Sun for half the
year and pointed away from the Sun for
the other half of the year when the
northern hemisphere is pointed towards
the Sun the sunlight hits more directly
and the days
longer this makes for summer in the
other half of the year northern
hemisphere is tilted away from the Sun
getting only slanted light for short
days and this makes for winter the tilt
is oriented such that the northern
hemisphere is pointing most towards the
Sun every June 21 the summer solstice
the northern hemisphere is pointed the
most away from the Sun every December 21
the winter solstice halfway between
these dates this Sun will equally
illuminate both hemispheres north and
south and these dates are called the
equinoxes the equinoxes are close to
every March 21 and September 21 the
solstice dates are connected with the
tilt of the Earth's orbit they're also
connected with the neverending seasonal
cycles of hot and cold the seasonal
cycle is connected with the changes in
the length of the day and also how high
the Sun gets in the sky during the day
the universal connections are easy and
obvious so all cultures from the
earliest times knew what was going on
for all ancient peoples these cycles in
the heavens were the only reliable
constant in their lives the livelihoods
of all hunter gathers and all farmers
depends critically on these seasonal
cycles and this is the reason for the
universal attention of all cultures to
the yearly Sun cycle another obvious
aspect of this yearly Sun cycle is the
periodic variations in the direction
along the horizon for the Rising Sun on
the March equinox the Sun rises exactly
towards the east on the next day the Sun
moves a little bit to the north in the
sky the sunrise position is just a
little bit north of east along the
horizon as the day's progress the Sun
Rise keeps moving more and more to the
north for typical northern latitudes by
April 21 the Sun is rising 16 degrees
north of East by May 21 this Sun is
rising 27 degrees north of East you're
stepping
the north slows down as Midsummer's
approached the northernmost sunrise
happens on the Solstice June 21 with a
sunrise position of 32 degrees north of
East again for typical northern
latitudes after the Solstice the sunrise
direction starts to move south picking
up speed until it again arrives exactly
to the east on the equinox September 21
for the next half year the position of
the sunrise closely mirrors the first
half of the year from September to
December the sunrise position is moving
south reaching its southernmost sunrise
point almost 32 degrees south of east on
December 21 the winter solstice from the
winter solstice to the March equinox
this sunrise position is moving north
then on March 21 the whole cycle starts
over again and this repeats endlessly
year after year the situation for sunset
direction is just a mirror of the
sunrise direction on March 21 and
September 21 the Sun sets exactly to the
west the Sun has its northernmost
sunset on the summer solstice and its
southernmost sunset on the winter
solstice the sunrise and sunset
positions are the most reliable and
easiest to measure aspect of the
seasonal cycle there's nothing special
about what happens on the day of the
equinox but their solstices are when
things turn around both the sunrise
changes and the seasonal changes with
the seasonal cycle being so critical for
all ancient peoples it's plausible that
these would be commemorated in stone and
architecture with this the primary
direction for archeoastronomy are the
eight cardinal and so official direction
in all our cue astronomy is looking for
the nearly universal commemoration of
the cardinal and social direction rarely
including star rise direction in the
monument admits of the ancient cultures
[Music]
Stonehenge is famous for the alignment
of its main axis towards a midsummer
sunrise the indicator direction is
simply the main axis of the monument
from the center over the slaughter stone
all over the heel stone and straight
down the Avenue if indicated direction
points towards a place on the horizon
where the Sun rises on midsummer day
June 21 if you stand at the center of
Stonehenge on this day you can see
through a gap between the two upright
stone under their lintel and with the
heel stone viewed in the middle just
poking up above the distant horizon and
that is where the solstice Sun rises
this basic astronomical alignment has
been recognized from antiquity but if
only in 1955 that this alignment
started a worldwide obsession with
Stonehenge this began with the
publication of the best-selling book
titled Stonehenge decoded by Gerald
Hawkins Hawkins was an astronomer then
share of the Astronomy Department at
Boston University on the back of the
book the blurb pushed one of the strong
and selling points as being that all of
the many astronomical calculations were
made with a computer the public was
intrigued by this recovery of long lost
ancient wisdom I remember my mom reading
the book to me back when I was a kid I
think that's 13 years old at the time
this book launched storms of protests
from archaeologists and the book
launched the whole field of
archeoastronomy Hawkins
computer work confirmed alignment on the
Solstice sunrise but he also proposed a
series of other alignments the main ones
are for station stones pointing towards
the extreme positions of moonrise that
is the station stone form a rectangle
and one pair of the sides points towards
the direction to the southeast or the
southernmost possible moonrise occurs
hawkins goes from the mere existence of
this site line to claim the de Beeker
people intentionally constructed this
alignment further Hawkins proposed an
imaginative way to use the 56 Aubrey
holes to form a computer to calculate
the dates of upcoming eclipses the idea
with the Dieker people a variety of
stone markers they placed in various
Aubrey holes and then move them around
on a set schedule and kept this up for
centuries when some particular stones
aligned then there would be the
possibility of an eclipse occurring so
Hawkins is claiming that Stonehenge is
not only an astronomical observatory but
also an analogue computer to predict
eclipses the end result of all this
astronomical research was the view that
Stonehenge was a marvelous astronomical
observatory millennia in advance of the
rest of the world in science
[Music]
okay so Stonehenge is this wonderful
ancient monument with astronomical
alignments but what does it all mean
well British antiquarians were the first
to pay attention and study Stonehenge
and they attributed the monument to
Merlin or the Druids the Druids were the
intelligence see of the Celtic peoples
through the British Isles they're
perhaps best known being religious
leaders with a passion for human
sacrifice
little is known about the Druids but
Julius Caesar tells us that they held
various lectures and discussions on
astronomy and on the extent and
geographical distribution of the globe
as part of their education well
if general view of Stonehenge has a
stronghold on the public imagination now
the most widespread picture of the
original Stonehenge is a druid religious
temple with human sacrifice starting in
1965 with Gerald Hawkins the
astronomical lineman's and the Eclipse
computer were widely taken to be the
critical component of Stonehenge to the
exclusion of most else with this it was
like astronomers were telling us that
Stonehenge was just one big astronomical
observatory and computer putting
together that two themes the fusion was
that some mystic druid astronomer
priests through all their society and
built Stonehenge for their own
astronomical observatory in the last
century modern pagans invented a new
religion centered at Stonehenge these
neo druids dressed up in white robes
sometimes with fake beards and paraded
around Stonehenge carrying large staff
these groups modeled their rituals on
what they imagined was done by ancient
peoples but there's certainly no
connection or basis with the real Iron
Age druids of Britain on the summer
solstices from 1974 to 1984 Stonehenge
became the venue of a free festival
featuring rock band on fixed stages and
free drug use the hippies would also get
into gang fights with motorcycle gangs
the British police finally suppressed
this in 1985 but hit the slot back in
what became known as the Battle of the
Beanfield for the rest of 537 people all
this rebranding of Stonehenge got absurd
in 2003 when a British Medical Journal
ran an article claiming that the
monumental design was intended to model
female genitalia authors were a pair of
Canadian Gynaecologists and
all this the archaeologists were telling
us that Stonehenge and all the tombs and
burial mounds in the area were just part
of a huge Neolithic burial grounds
it seems that were fated to have every
special interest group picturing
Stonehenge according to their own
interests antiquarium invoke druids
astronomer views and computers picture
the site as an observatory plus a
computer hippy views it as a party site
neo-pagans invent and religion centered
on the monument Gynaecologists
recognized genitalia and archaeologists
dig up a large burial complex however as
we'll see in the next lecture the real
picture for Stonehenge Arceus
and confident